I'm gonna tell you a story I've got a
story a story about me while the tragic
death has not officially been ruled a
homicide
Jerry Martha boy or girl the glasses and
that the Boy Scout shirt aren't we gonna
talk about what's happened fun should we
talk about all those fond memories we
have of Jamie how everyone thought he
was such a great guy who knew him anyone
down there is where I found him
he looked so scared crazy
I never thought anybody would be able to
see me I see you you have to stay away
from him Adam you can't give him what he
needs what if I could help them we are
not the only ones who've had tragedy
touch our lives who did it it was awful
it's hard to know whatever it is that
you're going through you can tell me I'm
not going through anything
yes fate brings people together for a
reason well what's that place there's
people all dead never let them hurt you
you are going to be the one that's sorry
save him everything's gonna be alright
I'm gonna tell you a story and then you
tell me one